c'est pas le chocolat
[Musique]
jaune
ouais
alors
quelle hauteur ça qu'est ce qu'être on a
gaffé l'imposant carré ouais c'est
la cour
[Musique]
non
x
[Musique]
voir
[Applaudissements]
et
demain
les deux organes
[Musique]
je vois j'ai pas fait en échec deux
années sans rien en peu plus au nord
comme un peu plus madame l'appel d'une
heure qu'on perde et les provinces
voisines à faire
brailsford
ce médecin parce que jamais que comme ça
les grosses
[Musique]
avec ce non pas comme moi à me wade noir
habilleuse lumière avec moi costumière
femmes de l'ombre et nicolas babel
technicienne pourtant non non non je ne
sais quand je suis pas la taupe
je suis torse nu et moi je voulais faire
un cadeau mais je meurs novartis et je
t'aime c'est à dire que tu es superbe